is i think he takes it personally i
think he is it's
man it's a freaking sport man this is
more to life than what it is because i
all fighting is my now man fighting is
not my life man
my life is my family man is my friend
the people i love this is what i do in
my life
is not my life i didn't even fighting is
is over it's over
i turn around and do something else you
know what i mean like is what i do in my
life
so my life you know what i mean it's not
the end of the world man is more
to to life than fighting well it's funny
hearing that from you because you would
you would expect to hear that from
someone who isn't considered one of the
greatest of all time but you're
considered one of the greatest of all
time so
it would be very art it would be very
hard to argue your approach
because it's been so successful they
they they
have to be super obsessed i'm super
obsessed
joe but that's why i become crazy then i
stopped for four years then when i came
back i
i some of my circuit and the brain
then i i started to analyze myself i'm
like why am
why become crazy why did i stop because
i'm taking this stuff too seriously man
you have to take it for what it is you
know like yeah it's a world championship
fight i'm fighting
i was fighting michael bismay after four
years people oh my god
the fight are promoted on drama
yeah and like john said john dinar he
says is i
fight are not one on drama our one
are on mundane things than we do
every day yeah that's how fight r1 yeah
how you program
program your your uh your crews
uh uh your your your your cruise driver
you know
your your your autopilot to win the
fight that's how you you you
me i see it i fight like an autopilot
you know like so when i fight when i
prepare myself for a fight especially
with a tactical part
i program like a computer how i want to
react
against that specific problem how i'm
gonna take care of that that specific
problem
the only way to program it is to do
repetition
repetition and repetition and repetition
and repetition
it's like yeah you said uh at one point
eddie bravo he said like
tying up your shoes yes because we've
been doing it so many times you can talk
to someone the same thing
yes when i get into a fight i analyze
again and i'm fighting
and i see what pattern he does the most
often
so i want to program my computer to
react to that pattern that would give me
the advantage into the fight
i don't know when that pattern would
occur but i want to program myself that
when it occur
i have an answer for it right away i
don't have to think about it i don't
think i just react and that's my problem
when i used to fight
and i got a lot of criticism before i
was thinking too much towards the end of
my career
i had so much pressure i didn't perform
as well as i was
earlier especially my last fight before
i i stopped for the four years i was
thinking too much overthinking
to putting too much pressure like you
said is too serious
you have to take it for what it is it's
only a fight in a
10 years you know it's you know it sucks
if you lose but man it is what it is you
know what i mean
don't take it for don't make it bigger
than what it is
it's only a fight and sometimes it's
something very therapeutic that i like
to do
before i fight i
drive a car i when i fight in vegas for
example i drive a car or new york same
thing
i drive a car when i used to fight in
vegas back before my fight i used to be
very very stressed and one a very
therapeutic thing that i
that i like to do is drive my car around
and see normal people then i go and i no
but i gotta explain to you
why i drive and i see an old lady with
our grocery store bag
and i'm thinking like she doesn't care
if i win the fight saturday or not
she's not even gonna hear about it then
i look oh it's another guy yelling to
another guy because he whatever problem
or this guy is going to the bank to pay
his
his mortgage stuff they don't care they
don't care you know
the effect that i have on the universe
is so freaking small
nobody cares i'm the only one putting
the pressure on me
nobody gives a damn about it so that's
why they helped me to perform now
that's how some of the younger guys say
i'm nervous how do
i heard you don't sleep well the night
before i said yeah it's true i don't
sleep well
is that what is your trick how do you
find a way to sleep well i was like wow
i don't really sleep well either
nowadays
i'll do but how do you feel better about
it like i just know that i'm not gonna
sleep well and it's not gonna affect the
outcome of the competition it's just a
normal thing you learn how to deal with
it better
you're not going to change it yeah just
accept it
yeah the stress is your friend man
that's going to make you react that's
going to be
on the edge have you ever slept well
before a fight never
never only one time which when i fought
myself
and i got knocked out
[Laughter]
and then after that knocked out i got so
scared that it happened again it's the
most humiliating
day of my career i was so
angry like i said i was like putting too
much on myself
it started there it's like i didn't want
to go to
to buy eggs at the grocery store right
because people
they say look he got knocked outside
like i thought everybody cares about me
nobody cares about you nobody cares only
a
small percentage of population nobody
gives a damn
and even if they do what you make a
mistake you
you zig when you should have zaggy to
get clipped so what everybody
make mistake you have to take fight like
it is you know it's a sporting event
that's why i don't take it personally
like when i have the problem with the
diaz bra
no problem and that fight is not
personal for me
you're you're in my life now you you
won't be there in 10 years maybe maybe
you will
who knows it's only like a chunk of life
that we share together
and then after he's gone no problem with
that that's definitely a better attitude
to look at yeah
that's what it is that's how athlete
they should think you know
and that's that knowledge that i have is
with
years of years of competition you know
all the the problem i have the colitis
and all that that's because of that
that that bs that i got it like putting
too much on me
it's normal if i fight again it will be
it will go back the same pattern
i will i will not be i will be very
stressed and it's normal to be stressed
but i will accept it i accept it better
now
than i used to do